today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
so let's start today with uh some policy
analysis
nothing nothing more exciting than that
for sure but this is actually very
interesting we we've talked before
uh in fact we spoke earlier on the bonus
show yesterday about this but i do want
to do a deeper dive on it because it's
very important a conservative think tank
did an analysis of joe biden's tax plan
and confirmed that the tax increases
will go
almost exclusively to the very rich and
will be stimulative to the economy
overall and this is so wild because
it's so obvious when you look at joe
biden's tax plan
that the tax hikes go overwhelmingly to
the top
five and one percent and yet republicans
and trump not only have been lying about
what's
in the plan they lie about the impact
that the plan will have so
let's set it up and go through it piece
by piece when donald trump was running
for president back in 2015 2016
and proposed his tax plan non-partisan
groups looked at it
and they said this is not going to
stimulate the economy
and it will blow up the deficit and of
course
every time donald trump was asked about
it when trump's advisors were asked
about it they would say no no no
what they're not calculating is that the
tax plan will grow the economy so much
that we will get new tax revenue so even
though it might
in the short term look like it increases
the deficit
the growth aspect will way override that
and we're going to get more tax revenue
and the economy will grow and all this
different stuff the deficit will
actually go down
we knew it wouldn't happen at the time
and it hasn't happened donald trump gave
tax cuts to the rich
the deficit exploded the growth hasn't
happened and this is
before coronavirus yes coronavirus has
thrown a monkey wrench into the entire
thing
but even pre-coronavirus it wasn't
happening so joe biden puts out a tax
plan and the tax plan includes
a number of different provisions higher
taxes for the very rich
he would uncap social security taxes
beyond four hundred thousand dollars in
annual income huge uh revenue increase
he would up tax capital gains as
ordinary income in certain cases for
certain people earning over a million
dollars a year
he would eliminate the stepped-up basis
loophole i don't have to explain each
item but the point is joe biden puts out
a specific tax plan
we look at it and it's unremarkable
given our understanding of economics
that joe biden's tax plan would work
perfectly reasonably if indeed it is
made law
donald trump has been hammering on
biden's tax plan by saying things like
he will quadruple your taxes
mathematical impossibility if you
already pay 35 percent how do you
quadruple that doesn't make any sense
uh trump says under biden's tax plan
your 401ks would implode
we would have a recession we would have
a depression all of that different stuff
and donald trump has been saying biden
will raise your taxes
if you are in the middle class if you're
a middle class american joe biden will
raise your taxes
biden clearly has said he wouldn't do it
okay now
financial firms like goldman sachs have
already looked at the plan
and they've confirmed what any
reasonable person would realize when
looking at the plan
and understanding history which is that
uh joe biden's tax plan would likely
grow the economy we know the economy
tends to do better under democratic
presidents we can debate why we can
debate whether it does better
enough but the reality is any indicator
you look at
inflation stock market job creation
unemployment gdp growth
historically they do better under
democratic presidents okay
but now in comes the right wing think
tank
the american enterprise institute this
is again a right wing think tank they've
analyzed the plan
and they agree that number one almost
all of the tax
increases that joe biden proposes go to
the richest
five percent of households and that joe
biden's tax plan
will reduce taxes for the bottom
95 of health households so top five
percent your taxes go up
bottom 95 percent taxes go down biden's
tax plan
according to the right wing think tank
aei
will raise federal revenue by nearly
three trillion dollars over the next
decade
it would be deficit negative and then
here is the real kicker
all of this stuff biden is going to do
trump says it will destroy the economy
okay all of it over 10
years will lower gdp get ready for this
by 0. percent
okay that's essentially nothing 0.16
decreased to gdp over a decade but and
here's the really amazing thing
demand side stimulus works my friends
biden's plan
is going to take some of that tax money
and spend it on social investments which
will
increase economic growth so in other
words
the direct impact of biden's tax plan
is an almost zero decrease of gdp
of 0.16 over 10 years
but it will create growth this is what
trump claimed his plan would do even
though it wouldn't
biden's plan would create growth such
that new tax revenues
would exceed the cost and we are
expecting that gdp would actually
increase more quickly thanks to this
plan
this is exactly what donald trump
claimed his plan would do
it didn't it was never going to but even
a right wing think tank acknowledges
that it is exactly what joe biden's plan
would do
we are in bizarro world with republican
voters continuing to fall for trump's
claims
that biden will be bad for the economy
that biden will tax
the middle class more he won't and by
the way
even if you want to argue that this will
be bad for the rich because the rich
will have to pay more taxes on
investment income
and pay higher estate taxes in the long
run
this is probably good for the rich as
well because when you stimulate
demand side in the middle class and
lower middle class
when you give tax cuts to lower income
people who will spend the money
where are they going to spend it those
people are going to go and spend the
money
at businesses owned by the rich
so understand that by by giving the
middle class a tax cut
you help the rich by funding government
programs
properly people will be able to get
vital services and better serve the
business interests
of the rich and every time we dig into
the details this is what we find and
this is nothing new
we've gone through this routine
analyzing trump's tax plan
barack obama's tax plan george w bush's
tax but
this goes back as long as we've been
doing this the political season changes
but understanding the fundamentals of
supposed supply-side economics
demand-side stimulus
we always end up in the same place and
even the right-wing think-tank here aei
american enterprise institute agrees
that that would indeed be the case
very interesting but not all together
surprising
uh the trump campaign and right wing
media have been falling all over
themselves over the last 24 hours to
promote a story by the new york post
a supposed game-changing
earth-shattering bombshell
about joe biden and the entire story may
be fake
at minimum it is not what we would call
reputable reporting
and i've gone back and forth over the
last 12 hours about whether to talk
about this today
i've received enough emails about this
that i do
want to discuss it at least briefly so
i want to give you the simplest
explanation of the story as it is
alleged
first then we'll talk about what we
actually know to be true
and whether this story matters so the
story is as follows
yesterday the new york post publishes an
article based on supposed emails
reportedly obtained from a laptop that
joe biden's son hunter biden
had allegedly left at a computer repair
shop in delaware in april of 2019.
so already we have a lot of if ands and
butts
speculation and unproven assertions
the gist of the supposed emails uh is
that hunter biden arranged for a top
ukrainian energy executive
to meet with joe biden who at the time
was the vice president
supposedly barista adviser vadim
pizarski
wrote an email to hunter biden and in
the email pizarski says to hunter biden
thank you for inviting me to dc and
giving an
opportunity to meet your father and
spend some time together
so instantly the trump campaign and the
right have been going crazy saying
see see joe biden lied this was a
conflict of interest hunter biden was
influence peddling while he was on the
board
of this ukrainian energy company burisma
biden lied it's all true
now if the story is true exactly as
described it would be a problem for joe
biden at least to some degree
although trump and his family have done
what joe biden is accused of doing
a hundred times over the trumpists don't
care there have been no repercussions
but yes if the story is true it would
lead to having to answer some questions
okay
but the thing is that now more serious
journalistic entities have
looked at the story the story may not
even be true
the first question is
this laptop a laptop was supposedly left
18 months ago in a repair shop
and the repair shop owner copied the
hard drive
and has now turned it over to rudy
giuliani and others
it's already very weird the emails that
are in the story
aren't actual screen shots of emails
there's no header info there's no
metadata it's a screenshot of a pdf
uh it's a screenshot pdf it could be
from a real email
it could be totally fake we don't know
next
even if the email that is uh
uh um purported to be an email to hunter
biden
is a real email to hunter biden it's not
clear if the email refers to something
that happened
or to something that the russian
executive is hoping happens he says in
the email
thank you for inviting me to dc that
could be
thank you for something that took place
or something that maybe could take place
thank you for giving me an opportunity
to meet your father unclear if that
actually took place and we'll get to
that
next even if it is what it purports to
be there's no indication that hunter
biden ever replied
to the email and the story doesn't even
allege that hunter biden replied
and officials who work for joe biden say
no such meeting
actually took place now in the meantime
the biden campaign has said
it's conceivable that at some event
biden might have shaken hands with this
ukrainian executive
along with dozens or hundreds of other
people this is a defense donald trump
often uses
uh donald trump will often claim he
doesn't know somebody pictures come out
of trump hugging the guy
and then trump says listen i take
millions they've actually said i've
taken
millions of pictures like that and the
trumpists are satisfied with that
explanation
so they conceivably should be satisfied
with that same explanation here if
indeed it is the explanation
and then the last reason to be skeptical
of all of this
is that rudy giuliani appears to be
behind all of it donald trump's
i guess still lawyer and henchman and i
would be at this point
looking at anything that comes from rudy
giuliani with skeptical eyes
in the end i think this changes nothing
about the election there are rumors
that much more on hunter biden is coming
if that happens then we will have to
examine it
and reevaluate whether it does anything
in terms of the election
this story from the new york post i
think does nothing
in terms of the election and if this is
the october surprise
it really is a very weak october
surprise if you disagree with me
let me know i'm on twitter at d pacman
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important
core insights from each book so it's
perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
join the uh discussion with nearly 25
000 other david pakman show viewers and
listeners on the david pakman show
subreddit you can find it at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t some interesting posts i
spotted this
morning user king versing
torix oh boy posted a link to an article
about donald trump retweeting a
conspiracy theory which claims that joe
that osama bin laden is still alive
and this actually did not get a lot of
attention but this is an example of the
hyper normalization that we are seeing
during this presidency when the
president of the united states
retweets and signal boosts something as
outrageous
as the conspiracy theories purporting
to claim and i say purporting to claim
because are they really claiming this in
a serious way
i don't know but purporting to claim
that osama bin laden for example was
never really killed
that should be major news and in many
other countries it would be grounds for
you know a vote to a no confidence vote
for the leader but it barely even made
news here in the united states really
bizarre stuff also from the subreddit
one of our viewers this is one of the
most
upvoted posts in history on the david
pakman show subreddit
one of our viewers who goes by the name
ok interview
posted a picture of herself
with a mask with a david pakman show
t-shirt now a collector's item
um and uh a an i voted sticker
voting early and reminding everybody to
be
safe out there a beautiful post much
loved much loved by the david pakman
show reddit community
let us know if you've been voting early
how it's been going i got a few emails
and different pictures from people at
different polling places a lot of people
voting early
and then lastly user fd kaplan
is making a request of me a vocabulary
request
saying let's avoid using the word
interregnum
and use interim instead and it is a
linguistic
etymological request f d
kaplan says that interregnum quite
literally means
between kings and that it feels
inappropriate to use what is typically a
metaphorical
reference to kings when donald trump is
maybe not going to accept the results of
the election
in a pseudo effort to declare himself
king so i will use it the interim period
or
what i hope is the lame duck period
that's really the term i want to be
using
maybe interregnum wasn't the right word
join the discussion as more than 24 000
nearly 25 000 of you already have
on the subreddit at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t so we've been um
we've been following donald trump's
recovery from coronavirus
it's been a very up and down erratic
period with various completely
unbelievable and deceptive claims from
donald trump's doctor and
donald trump triumphantly returning to
the white house
and then gasping for air visibly we've
been tracking it all we know donald
trump has received a variety of
different medications and we've also
observed this week donald trump has
again gone back to doing rallies this
week
and we've observed that in the evenings
at the rallies
trump seems hopped up and i mean that
colloquially he's speaking very very
quickly
uh he's more red and i think this is
even accounting for the makeup he's more
red and sort of sweaty than we typically
see
and the speculation of course is that he
is still either receiving steroids as
part of his treatment which are
kind of giving him this energy or
possibly he's being given a steroid
like to suppress a cough and to energize
him because he is still
potentially struggling with the effects
of coronavirus as we know
from the millions of cases of
coronavirus that we've now seen
sometimes you'll have this five to seven
day period and you'll be feeling better
and then later you'll be feeling worse
and it can be tough to shake it
sometimes even for months particularly
for folks in their 70s and 80s
as donald trump is well yesterday we had
a trump event earlier in the day for the
first time in a while donald trump's
events have tended to be in the evenings
earlier in the day yesterday donald
trump apparently
not juiced up and his voice was
completely failing
suggesting he is really not doing as
well as he would like us to think
and of course with coronavirus it could
go
any way at any time in terms of a return
to more serious symptoms so take a look
at this first clip this is from an event
trump did he was in the rose garden and
he was speaking via
uh teleconference to a number of
different economic
clubs the new york economic club and i
think a couple of others
and trump just really struggling here
take a look at this
simply put it's a choice between a
socialist nightmare and
the american dream and this continued
throughout the entire event here's
another one of these just
pausing struggling to speak having to
catch his breath clearing throat cough
etc
instead of corrupting horrendous trade
deals written by lobbyists and special
interests
again some of you i negotiated
pro-american trade deals
based on the principles of fairness and
reciprocity
very important i ended the
nafta nightmare and signed the brand new
u.s mexico canada agreement into law
i've taken the toughest ever action
against chinese chronic
great abuses that we all know so well
really sounding terrible and of course
this is naturally
you know he's 74 and he had coronavirus
a week ago causing
speculation to run rampant about is
trump contagious
how serious is trump's case what are the
symptoms he's having should he really be
doing these rallies
now of course sounding like that doesn't
mean you're contagious
sounding like that doesn't even mean
it's not even necessarily because of
coronavirus people get coughs and
difficulty speaking from non-coronavirus
uh of viruses and conditions as well but
it does raise questions about just how
well donald trump is doing
now also during this event trump
referred it wasn't just how he sounded
the things he said also were extremely
disturbing trump referenced globalists
again
and that's another one of those words
where we wonder does trump
know that in many right-wing circles and
conspiratorial circles globalist
is code for crafty jews that these are
sort of interchangeable terms
or does trump not have any idea we don't
know but trump using the term
anyway the last administration sold out
american workers like never before
and they sold them to donors special
interests and globalists and if you take
a look we have probably plenty of them
watching right now
and i understand where you're coming
from but didn't work out too well with
me
so yeah that that is a term that um has
signif much like america first which
sounds sort of innocuous
but has a very ugly past that is a term
with an ugly past and unclear if donald
trump knows it of course
as far as we know other people are
writing donald trump's speeches
hard to tell sometimes whether trump is
ad-libbing or reading off of the
prompter
who knows but trump continuing to use
that term without really understanding
it
donald trump also claimed during this
event that the country if joe biden is
elected
will experience a worse depression than
1929.
take a listen to this because they will
destroy this country
our country will go into a depression
the likes of which we have not
seen since 1929 and maybe worse
so keep backing them but you know it's
wrong and i really do believe
it's only habit that's the only reason
you can be doing it
under my continued leadership so we've
looked at this in depth
if you watch this show if you listen to
my podcast you know that the economy
does better
under democratic presidents than
republicans there is no qualitative
or quantitative case to be made that
would support
a cratering economy if joe biden is
president and as we talked about earlier
today even the right-wing american
enterprise institute says
joe biden's tax plan would actually be
be
fine for the economy and the tax hikes
would go to the richest five percent 95
percent of the country would get a tax
decrease under joe biden so not based in
fact
donald trump continuing to use the
talking point
that he saved two million lives
by whatever it is he did on coronavirus
although if it weren't for trump he
wants you to believe 2.2 million people
would have died take a look
our aggressive and early action saved up
to 2 million lives
if you look at the original numbers it
was projected at 2.2 million
lives where at 210 000 and one is too
many it should have never happened
should have never been allowed to happen
by china
thanks to advances and treatment so i i
i almost don't want to do this but i
think
i should do it this is the way that the
numbers go
uh first donald trump said we had 15
cases and they would soon be zero
donald trump then said we were going to
keep the death toll under 50
000 then under 60 000 once it got to 70
he said it would be under 100.
once it got to 100 trump said it would
be under 200 once it became clear it
would be more than 200 now donald trump
is saying listen
2.2 million people could have died so
that's the number
if literally no one does anything and
remember even if trump did nothing
as he did nothing initially governors
were still going to do things so this
idea of 2.2 million deaths is ridiculous
but here's where the number comes from
331 million people live in the united
states
if you assume no measures whatsoever
until there is herd immunity it just
spreads
that would suggest about 70 of the
country would get the virus at that
point you would have achieved herd
immunity so 70
of 331 million is about 231 million
people
with a one percent death rate or just
below 1
death rate if you do nothing and 70
of the country gets infected you would
expect somewhere between 2.1
and 2.3 million people to die but again
that is doing nothing
that's every other country does stuff
and we do nothing no governors do
anything no
masks trump does nothing it's a crazy
comparison
it's laughable and idiotic to still be
mentioning it
but because we went from zero deaths
to 50 000 60 70 80 100 200 now 220
000 or more donald trump now has to say
well listen we could have lost 2.2
million people
uh i don't think trump would have
survived a situation
in which the death toll was going to be
2.2 million but that's a story
probably for a different day we'll
continue discussing this
on the david pakman show instagram david
pakman show
and while you are on instagram follow me
at david.pacman we'll take a quick break
and be back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
robert p jones is the ceo of the public
religion research institute and also
author of the new book white too long
the legacy of white supremacy
in american christianity uh robert
thanks for your time really appreciate
it
oh thanks yeah i'm great i'm really glad
to be here so let's uh
just just just to get us into this topic
can you talk a little bit about i mean
how how far
back does the um interplay or overlap
between white supremacy and american
christianity go
and is it a specific to certain
denominations
that's a great yeah opener um well it
goes all the way back
um you know is the thing there is to say
i mean all the way back to the founding
of the republic and in fact
you know what the the version of uh kind
of particularly white protestant
christianity that lands on american
shores
um you know brings with it this
entanglement with white supremacy really
from its european
uh european roots um so things like
manifest destiny
uh the idea that white europeans are
entitled to native american lands
all the way from the very beginning i
mean these are very much wrapped up with
um this entanglement of the idea that
kind of white uh white people are meant
to be over others in kind of a racial
hierarchy
and that this was legitimated by
christian belief and it kind of brought
and kind of came over legitimated and
packaged in
a kind of white christian theological
package uh when we look
at the um the northern baptist southern
baptist
split which is something that has been
written about
from a number of different angles over
the years um
how much was that split related to this
issue of white supremacy
yeah well it was it was the reason uh
really that uh
you know baptist the north and baptist
in the south parted ways it was
literally over
whether a uh ordained member of the
clergy
could enslave other human beings on the
basis of the color of their skin
and still you know retain their status
as a as a clergy person and that whether
this was a legitimately christian
thing to do and babson the north
rejected that view baptist and the south
were so dedicated
uh to protecting um you know not only
this possibility but this as
a christian norm uh that they literally
split from their northern brother and
set up their own um
you know convention called the southern
baptist convention that's where that
name comes from
uh in 1845 so this is well before um
even the civil war um and this is my
home denomination i should say and that
i grew up in
as a southern baptist in mississippi um
and uh but you know that history i think
one of the reasons why i wrote the book
is um that history is not well known
really i mean even even i growing up
inside the church didn't find out about
it until i was in seminary so my early
in my early 20s but the one thing to say
to answer the first part of your
question to
your first question is that while i
think this history is most
um kind of on the surface with a with an
organization like the southern baptist
convention
virtually every protestant denomination
split
over the issue of slavery and white
supremacy um in the civil war the
methodist split
the presbyterian split the episcopalians
uh you know spit
split um and it was all really over this
question
of the legitimacy of of slavery and then
underneath that the kind of you know
bigger
thing that um that justifies that this
idea
of white of white supremacy is or to
what degree is the catholic church sort
of
exempt from this i mean i know you said
that this was predominantly um
in in protestant churches but what about
the catholic church
right uh really important as well i mean
what we find is that um you know
despite the fact that the catholics have
their own history of discrimination you
know in in the us
there's a lot of anti-catholic sentiment
you know as late as john f kennedy's
um you know presidential election he was
facing a lot of anti-catholic
uh sentiment in in 1960 but um
you know it is worth saying too that but
in the latter years um this this problem
really exists
it actually exists you know through the
catholic church as well so for example
even in new york
um you know not in the south uh but in
new york city
um you know there was one catholic
parish as as african-americans began to
move in numbers from the south to new
york
as part of the great migration they were
displacing in many cases
irish neighborhoods polish neighborhoods
italian neighborhoods
and pushing uh folks out and they
actually left
because they didn't want to live
alongside americans and
and then even the the diocese in um in
new york
designated one diocese saint mark's
parish or one one parish
saint mark's parish as the place for
african americans to go so in other
words if you're white in new york you
could go to your local
hair school if you want to go to
catholic school but if you were
african-american there was one
school you had to go to they had
segregated all african-americans into
one school
african-americans often had to wait at
the end of the line
until all whites had received the
eucharist at a mass
before they could receive eucharist and
this is again in catholic churches in
new york
uh so it really has infected really not
only kind of
evangelicals in the south or mainline
protestants in the midwest but also
catholics that are more numerous in
urban and northeastern settings
i'm guessing that the answer to this
question i'm guessing there are multiple
answers to this question that that may
vary but
what have been some of the biblical
justifications for
for slavery and then short of slavery
discrimination or out outward racism
yeah um you know so i spent a whole
chapter in the book talking about the
kind of theology and kind of how this
creeps in
uh and is embedded in in white christian
theology
one of the most blatant examples um
really is that
white christians really invented a
separate creation story
uh for black and brown people that was
separate from the creation story
for white people so uh and and read this
back into the book of genesis and uh it
was in the story of um
cain and abel these are um two brothers
cain kills his brother abel because he's
jealous
and then lies to god about the murder um
and in the in the text it says that god
marks him kind of it marks him as a
result
now the text doesn't say anything about
skin color or race or any any of that
but white theologians and clergy
and white christians in general read
back into that passage aha here's the
beginning
of dark-skinned people that's their
origin story
now that conveniently right traces then
whites back to adam and eve to these
kind of more noble human beings
that god formed by god's own hands and
breathed life into them
uh and then traces the origin story of
um
non-white peoples in the world literally
to a criminal act um that is that is the
you know to a murder
um and so it it sets up a kind of not
only kind of racial hierarchy but a
moral hierarchy
with whites having this more noble
history and non-whites having this um
you know history that again goes back to
an original ancestor
who is literally a murderer more
recently
um and but you know during the 20th
century so to speak
uh we started to see groups like the kkk
uh come to prominence in certain parts
of the country
and uh the the the identity of the
kkk as a christian group is something
that is much discussed and to different
extents debated but as my understanding
uh
remains today they at least
self-identify
as as a christian group can you talk a
little bit about that
and the relationship between the kkk and
particular denominations
uh sure you know they it it's worth
noting
that that's exactly right that the kkk
um was
very um explicitly christian um
and to be very specific they were
protestant christian um right so what's
what's lost often is
you know people think about them burning
crosses against
americans in the country but uh what's
worth remembering is that they were not
only
an anti-black organization but they also
saw jews and catholics
as a threat uh to a protestant america
that they were out to defend i mean they
were very explicitly
defending a white anglo-saxon protestant
version of america um and you know so
and so they they were uh yeah they they
were very vehemently anti-catholic saw
them as a threat to democracy and
anti-jewish
um you know as well uh so a lot of
anti-semitism
and anti-catholicism you know really
traces its way back there
and i think the thing that that survives
and sort of like is more diffuse
in in particularly white protestant
circles is this
is this melding of white anglo-saxon
protestantism with american identity
right i think that this is one of the
things we're still struggling with today
that that white christians in many ways
and particularly white protestants
historically saw themselves as
america right um and and and so the with
the changing demographics of the country
today
uh white christians today for example um
are only 44
of the country that's if you take all of
them together and just a decade ago
there were 54
percent of the country so this is a
quite recent sea change that we've been
through
and i think some of the visceral things
in our politics and particularly i think
the appeal of of trump when he has
talked to white christians in particular
has been to appeal to this white
anglo-saxon protestant version of
america that he
is standing in to protect uh from change
as the country is shifting
um quite dramatically over the last 10
or 15 years
last thing i want to touch on speaking
now in in the modern era you know in the
right now and over the last 10 to 15
years
what is the landscape like in terms of
denominationally the sort of more
uh integrated and a progressive for lack
of a better term
protestant denominations versus on the
other side the ones that
still maintain more of the segregation
and division
yeah well you know i'd like to say they
were uh
that i had found in my research a great
deal more
distinction than i in fact found i think
is one of the more
surprising findings of the book is that
um despite the fact that if you look at
the denominational level and you look at
like statements for example that
denominations have put out
the mainline protestant denominations
that are part of the national council of
churches for example have put out lots
of statements about racial justice
about black lives matter those kinds of
things that if you just read those
statements you would think that the
domination is those denominations are
kind of way over here yeah um whereas
you've heard much less from
the national association of evangelicals
for example um and
and other evangel the southern baptist
convention other other groups you've
heard much less from them
but the thing is if you get away from
those elite actors and you look at
actually people in the pews
as we've done in national public opinion
surveys um just
real quickly example i developed in the
book a thing i call a racism index which
is a measure of
attitudes about structural racism across
15 different questions
and if you use a metric like that and i
scored that index on a scale of one to
ten
um it's maybe not that surprising with
10 being holding the most racist
attitudes that white evangelicals score
8 out of 10
um on that index but here's what's
surprising is that white mainline
protestants again these are
episcopalians
presbyterians uh united church christ
and methodists
um uh scored seven out of ten on that
same index and as did white catholics
white catholics scored seven
out of ten and if you take whites who
are not um religiously and
are not christian they only score four
um out of ten on the same index so the
big divider really
among white americans today is christian
identity and christian identity moves
average white people further away
actually from the concerns of racial
justice that african americans have have
in the country
that was one of the more remarkable i
think finding the book is just that
distance
uh and and that it is really it is
christian identity that really is doing
the work of kind of moving
uh whites um who are christian further
away
from the concerns of african americans
than whites who are not that's it do you
out of curiosity do you have
numbers on that scale for for example uh
mormons jews and muslims
so um we don't have enough for mormons
they weren't big enough to break out and
we don't have enough
for jews and muslims individually but
when we break out we put together like
non-christian religious people so jews
muslims hindus buddhists
i don't remember the numbers straight up
but they are further much further down
the scale than white christians are
um uh on on these questions much more
sympathetic to the views of
african-americans and racial justice
issues um than our than our white
christians so white christians are
really staking out the higher end of
that
um sticking out the higher end of that
scale that's uh that that's absolutely
fascinating the the book
is white too long the legacy of white
supremacy
in american christianity we've been
speaking with the book's author
robert p jones who's also ceo of public
religion research
institute robert i so appreciate your
time today
hello thanks for having me great to talk
to you the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
there was an interesting exchange on cnn
during an interview
with donald trump's economic advisor
larry kudlow and kudlow didn't
necessarily seem drunk this time
although he did have some interesting
hiccups during the interview and and
some some kind of strange slurring but
he he wasn't making sense regardless of
whether he had been drinking i think is
the point i'm trying to make and larry
kudlow tried telling cnn anchor jake
tapper
that the united states is dealing with
coronavirus in a safe way and that the
trump administration has figured out how
to do it now
fact check before we watch the video as
of right now
the united states is the major country
with the eighth
most cases per capita in the world and
the ace
eighth most deaths per capita in the
world now when i say major country
there are tiny uh territories like san
marino for example
which have worse numbers on a per capita
basis than the us
it only moves the u.s up two spots so so
so it's not a
a big change in either case but trump
and people around him
despite these horrible numbers continue
to insist
partially out of desperation partially
out of dishonesty that the united states
is just doing great on the virus
and larry kudlow tried saying it to jake
tapper and jake tapper just laughed in
larry kudlow's face and it's compelling
to watch let's take a look
and kudlow you will hear shifting
directly from singing the praises of the
economy
into singing trump's praises on
coronavirus and jake tapper just can't
take it
my point is this we are in a strong
rebound
lower taxes and lower regulations going
way back
are still in place and businesses are
reopening we are learning to deal with
the virus
in a targeted safe prevented way so
it's not dependent all i'm saying is a
little some
targeted assistance would go a long way
we're not we're not learning to live
with the virus
larry that we just had four days in a
row of more than 50 000 infections the
death rate is the highest in the world
but
let's focus on the the economic aspect
because that's your area of expertise
i guess one i just want to say yeah just
jake one to check one just one second
i want to clarify living with the virus
look
uh 5 000 experts just signed a petition
uh led by people from harvard stanford
oxford university
these are scientists these are doctors
these are health care workers who say
we can deal with this virus going on
while
we're getting new therapies we're
getting new vaccines are coming around
it's not just living with the virus as
long as we protect the most vulnerable
as long as we preserve the key
guidelines yes we can get through this
we are not going to shut down the whole
economy no nobody there is no reason for
that
we will take care of the vulnerable
that's the key point well
and there's so much that you just said
but again i had you on to talk about the
economy
not not health care matters in terms of
obeying by the key guidelines i mean you
might want to tell the guy
in the building behind you but that's a
separate issue so jake's mistake there
is he referred to the building behind
kudlow as if kudlow was at the white
house and it said on screen kudlow
was actually at his country estate in
connecticut
for the interview not at the white house
but jake tapper is right to laugh
record number of cases for the last two
months once again
four days ago over the weekend and if we
want to look not just at one day but at
the seven day moving average
the average cases have been increasing
since september 13th so we are now a
full month into
another spike and remember when you look
at this graph you see we had that first
spike into mid april
and then we got back down to about 20
000 cases a day and for some reason at
20
000 cases a day everything opened up and
then we spiked to 75
000 cases a day in mid-july you can see
it on the graph
now we've had more openings since
dipping
to 35 000 cases a day and we're back up
to 50 cases a day so
unfortunately there are people who saw
getting down to 35 000 cases a day
as a victory it's not a victory and if
this
trend continues the next peak could be a
hundred thousand cases a day and if
that's the case
it is going to be a very very dark
winter both uh
literally as uh the clocks get ready to
change uh
and and it is going to be this sunset
will be very early in the northeast
and metaphorically it will be a very
dark winter as dr fauci said
we need to get down to an average of 10
000 cases a day
to even remotely being able to say we
are controlling the virus
and even 10 000 cases a day is a lot the
last time
think about this number the last time we
had only 10 000 cases per day
was last march since then every day
there are at least 10 000 cases some
days as many as 75
000 cases now as far as larry kudlow is
concerned kudlow
said back in february that the trump
administration had contained the virus
february i mean it's laughable
and as a reminder the official
coronavirus death toll
is likely way too low in the united
states this is something
we talked about maybe two months ago and
i think is worth revisiting
officially 221 thousand 222
have died from coronavirus that's a
massive
stunning tragic number and it didn't
have to be that way but that's the
official number
mortality in the united states was
more than 280 000 deaths higher
than during the first eight months of
2020.
then sorry during the first eight months
of 2020
mortality was more than 280 000 deaths
higher
than during any previous fought period
of the first eight months of the year
going back five years
so again it looks like the official
death toll of 221
is well below the real coronavirus death
toll
and you also have to remember because of
the virus fewer people are traveling
fewer people are walking around driving
around
you probably have to subtract out some
deaths
from some other causes because there are
people
just sitting at home reducing the number
of deaths from
other causes this year but kudlow
and others and trump himself continue to
insist we've won
we're winning we're the best it's over i
don't know that anybody believes it at
this point i think even when they
interview trumpists at rallies and they
say we've won
i don't even know that they believe it
to be totally honest with you
hey this is really interesting our
friend mehdi hassan has a new show on
peacock peacock as i understand it is
a new streaming network offshoot of nbc
or
msnbc it's it's nbc related one of the
nbc's
and mehdi interviewed former trump
national security adviser john bolton
now john bolton was also one of the
architects of the iraq war
i don't think john bolton knew what to
expect when he was interviewed by mehdi
i don't think he realized he was going
to be confronted brutally by mehdi
hassan
it's really a pleasure to watch so let's
dig into a clip where
maddie hassan asking john bolton whether
he regrets all the people that died
as a result of the iraq war which bolton
pushed and helped orchestrate let's get
into the first clip
so let's talk about the the complex
issues you said you wanted to discuss
you say in your book
that unlike mike pompeo who had to
recant his support for the iraq war
during senate confirmation hearings you
didn't have to uh because you were not
confirmed by the senate as national
security advisor
and correct me if i'm wrong you don't
have any regrets you never have
apologized for the iraq war unlike a lot
of other former supporters of it like
joe biden
so what i'm wondering is all those
thousands of people who died in iraq all
of those innocent iraqi civilians men
women children
killed by us airstrikes some of them in
massacres at haditha mehmudia
none of those weigh on your conscience
none of those deaths ever keep you up at
night
you don't know what you're talking about
the the iraq war
which was the period that lasted about
four weeks
and resulted in the overthrow of saddam
hussein
was a brilliant military victory by the
united states and other coalition forces
and that the removal of saddam hussein
from power
was the right idea at the time and it's
true today
where the united states made a mistake
and i've said this repeatedly
over the years was in the period
following the overthrow of saddam
hussein i do not think
we should have set up a coalition
provisional authority i think we should
have kept
our troops in iraq for a lot of reasons
but i think we should have turned
responsibility for the government
over to iraqis as soon as possible you
do not increase
a people's political maturity by making
decisions for them
you increase their political maturity by
making them make decisions for
themselves
so people talk about the iraq wars
though it started in 2003
and lasted until 2011 when obama
withdrew everybody
as if every single decision in that
eight-year period
followed inevitably unalterably from the
single decision to invade
in 2003 and that's simply not right this
is super interesting because it's a
really cynical
way of looking at the war when john
bolton says listen
the war was four weeks it was a single
military operation
and we won it everything else that
happened is not the war it's other stuff
and decisions made by other people
this is like saying listen vietnam
itself didn't really cause that much
chaos
uh you know endless
numbers of veterans needing treatment
for life and political problems
it was really the management in the five
years that followed the vietnam war that
were the problem we can't really blame
the vietnam war for all of those
problems
well would any of that have been the
issue an issue if we didn't go into
vietnam in the first place so when john
bolton says it was a four-week thing
that went fine
as a military operation everything else
wasn't the iraq war
including all the troops and civilians
that died after the four weeks it's
laughable
imagine a surgeon saying listen the
brain
surgery itself went fine i mean okay as
a result the patient had three years of
complications and bad outcomes but
that other doctors were dealing with
that the surgery itself was fine
any reasonable person would say these
are the uh complications
that are part of the package when you
decide to do the surgery you own the
complications as well
you hopefully understood
that the risks were understood and
necessary
given the reason you did the surgery but
you don't just walk away and say that's
somebody else's problem
let's watch a little more and meddy
hassan actually makes this point to john
bolton
you say it's simply not right but the
reality is hundreds of thousands of
iraqis died there was torture
millions of refugees and that did follow
from the decision by george w bush dick
cheney and others in the administration
like yourself to invade iraq
hundreds of thousands of people died and
just to go back to my question which you
didn't answer
do those deaths never do those deaths
never weigh on your conscience was my
question which you didn't answer
no i did answer and i'll answer it again
since you didn't seem to listen to it
the the fact was after the overthrow of
saddam hussein
a number of decisions could have been
made in different ways
i don't believe in u.s participation
in nation-building i think nations have
to build
themselves now this is just outrageous
bolton doesn't believe in u.s nation
building
during the iraq war which bolton by the
way says was four weeks long
during the iraq war all these neocons
were talking about
spreading democracy to iraq and he now
says he doesn't believe in nation
building and he wasn't the guy
involved in those decisions he knew what
the
bush administration planned to do and
for him to now say well
they didn't involve me in those
decisions
give me a break he believes in four
weeks of military
and saying we're done and now it's up to
them and he has nothing to do with it
and it continues in this
bizarre way and had the united states
followed through with that approach
rather than
engaging in extensive nation building
the outcome i think could well have been
very different
but delay what happened in iraq
on the single decision to overthrow
saddam hussein
is historically completely wrong but no
one's doing that they're pointing to the
war and the invasion and the occupation
you're trying to disconnect the
occupation
with respect john bolton you weren't you
weren't a pundit on fox news that you
were in government i don't remember you
quitting
in objection to the occupation and the
fact is that occupation
that occupation let me just finish my
question you come back in that
occupation produced
thousands of dead torture refugees uh
richard clarke who was white house
counter terrorism
tsar at the time uh shortly after 9 11
called
war crimes kofi and called the war
illegal i just wonder do you ever worry
that
you know people have tried to do
citizens arrests on you in the past do
you ever worry
you may have to face a court to answer
for that war on that occupation
for the war crimes that happened back
then uh
of course not because what you're saying
is completely ludicrous
and those who made those kinds of
criticisms are
not reflecting what actually happened uh
and i made clear in my first book
surrender is not an
option that i was largely excluded from
actual decision making on iraq by colton
powell
because he felt i had a different point
of view than he did
so my my observations here are from
somebody who
had a pretty good idea what was going on
inside
didn't agree with it but didn't have
much influence over policy i'm not
trying to duck the issue
but but you're making a grievous factual
error
when you attribute everything that came
after the overthrow of saddam
to the u.s decision to do that that's
called the post hoc ergo propter hawk
fallacy
look it up okay while i look it up let
me just ask you that question one more
time you keep saying i'm not listening
to you but i've asked twice i'll ask one
third time because i want to talk about
iran in the nuclear deal i know you have
strong views there
very quickly on iraq you have no regrets
about the thousands of iraqis who died
in iraq after the invasion they never
bother you never keep you up at night
never away on your conscience
i didn't say that at all and what i'm
saying is that the
the actual casualties and the overthrow
of saddam hussein
i understand that but you're still not
answering the question so i think you
get the picture there
of how that all went not not well uh
super interesting
and i've been watching clips of the
mehdi hassan show he he's very good at
this
and uh we're going to continue following
and seeing
uh what other interviews he lands but
this is very very interesting and it's
i encourage you to watch the full
interview because seeing john bolton
listen
there's no denying john bolton is an
intelligent guy and that john bolton
is a very articulate um
advocate for his completely hair-brained
neo-conservative foreign policy you you
can't watch and say this guy's an idiot
particularly when you can compare him to
the people in power
right now including donald trump um but
he was not prepared to actually defend
the morality of what he helped to
orchestrate because there it's
you're trying to defend the indefensible
quite frankly and that was very much
exposed during that interview
we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
here's a caller who doesn't like trump
but
doesn't really like biden and is
thinking of voting third party let's
take a listen
hi i was just watching your last video
about how
out of control donald trump is and i
agree with you
i do not want this man re-elected right
but i would not like
biden put into office either because
the lesser two evils is still evil have
you looked into joe jorgensen the
libertarian candidate
and if not you should and i would love
to actually get a call and be on your
platform
to speak my opinion as to why i'm voting
libertarian and maybe you could give the
libertarians
a chance to get the spotlight since they
will not allow her on the debate stage
okay so listen um i don't know what
state you're voting in
but you need to i really clearly
identify
who do you want less trump or biden
if you want trump less than you want
biden
voting third party again depending on
where you live
is de facto helping donald trump
so no i'm not going to be voting third
party this year
i'm with noam chomsky i'm with bernie
sanders
on the importance of removing donald
trump uh this idea of
the lesser of two evils is still evil
you know it's like at a certain point
we have to stop assigning these words to
it if you
take a scale let me even do this right
now if you take a scale
that goes from good to evil okay you've
got good at the top
and you've got evil at the bottom it
doesn't really matter
where it goes from being good to evil
like you could say well it goes from
good to evil here
or it goes from good to evil here all
that matters is
if you put trump closer to evil
then you put biden doesn't matter how
you characterize it then you've got to
vote for biden that's it
it's it's really that simple and i i
think that noam chomsky
in the clips we played earlier this week
did a fantastic job of distilling this
down
to its most fundamental basic components
uh review that clip if you're interested
but no i will be voting for biden i
believe we all should
and then we actually have a chance at
being activists for policies that make
sense under trump we have no chance and
that's what we've seen
over the last four years on the bonus
show today we will talk about
uh more news related to the post office
i won't even tell you what it is we'll
talk about it
we will also talk about some studies now
that are connecting blood type and
coronavirus
infection risk which are very
interesting we'll also talk about south
carolina
medicaid and planned parenthood all of
those stories
and more and more is important on
today's
bonus show also join me tonight at 7 30
pm eastern
for the trump town hall followed by the
joe biden town hall
in lieu of the second debate which has
been cancelled
that is tonight on youtube twitch and
facebook i will see you then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor
is blinkist the app that lets you read
or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to com slash david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video